a few months ago i made a video about a
difficult turkish exam question and that
video seemed to resonate with a lot of
people there were comments in turkish
that were glad that people could see the
pain that they had to go through and
there were plenty of comments lamenting
the state of the education system let me
show you some of the comments that
gained a lot of support this one
translates to you only have a black pen
but create a rainbow this is a summary
of the turkish education system and this
one says that the questions are of high
quality but unfortunately there is no
system that will take us to the answers
of those questions now i have never
studied in turkey and i don't know
enough to agree or disagree with these
statements but they do relate to a
larger sentiment that we see in many
other countries
and that is that the exam is not the
challenge the real challenge is
competing against the other students the
exam in question is the ayt paper used
to gain entrance into turkish
universities
the population of turkey is 85 million
and over two million students are taking
this test hoping to be in the top 50 000
to get into the good universities when
entry is so competitive you see exams
getting harder to try and separate
people but many are left feeling
frustrated by the fact that making exams
harder doesn't raise the quality of
education and instead can leave students
feeling dejected and hating school this
comment said geography is destiny and
this one said may god help turkish
indian and south korean students
assumably talking about the tough exams
they all have another common thread was
people saying that even if you're lucky
enough to ace this exam get into a good
university and graduate that there are
still not many jobs waiting for you at
the end this oecd unemployment rate data
does show that turkey has a pretty high
unemployment rate the latest figures are
around 11.2 percent whilst the usa and
the uk are at four percent and australia
4.2
it also seems like a lot of the top
students aspire to go overseas
contributing to what they call brain
drain where a country's brightest people
aren't sticking around to help it grow i
plan to work through another one of the
tough questions from the ayt exam paper
and i will get to doing that in this
video but first i got distracted by
another comment that told me to check
out the lgs exam given to middle
schoolers in turkey as a high school
entrance exam it is very hard a math
question this year was taken from the
university exam they are literally
forcing students to solve university
level questions at age 13 to 14. so
naturally i wanted to take a look here's
the paper and yes it's really hard
apparently students studying for this
are putting in eight plus hour study
days making it the youngest example of
that kind of hard work i've seen for an
exam yet let's take a look at the last
question on the math section we've got
these pie charts which show the
distribution of televisions sold in an
electronic store in 2019 and 2020 k l
and m are three different types of
televisions it says that while the
number of l brand televisions sold in
the store in 2020 decreased by 25
compared to 2019
the m brand televisions increased in
number by 40. according to this
what is the number of k brand
televisions sold in 2019 so we want to
know how many televisions does this
slice of pie represent that would be
easy to do if for example we knew how
many televisions were sold in total
either in 2019 or 2020 but that's not
information that we have so this becomes
quite tricky please do have a go at
solving it and while you're at it i
would like to quickly thank the sponsor
of this video babel i've done a lot of
translating to try and read these exam
questions and the comments and i've
actually been using babble to learn just
the basics from the turkish language to
make it easier for me to pick out
keywords babel is a top language
learning app that teaches real-world
practical conversations through
10-minute interactive lessons as well as
podcasts games videos and live classes
babel teaches more than just vocab words
and also teaches you about the languages
culture people history and traditions
[Music]
learning a new language is the perfect
way to work on yourself in 2022 and
rabble is offering a 20-day money-back
guarantee
you can get 65 percent off by going to
my link which is down in the description
and now let's take a look at the
solution so there might be a number of
ways to solve it but the simplest way i
found was to try and find out how many
tvs each degree of the pie represents
i'm going to define this variable x
which is how many tvs there are in each
degree of the pie in 2019 and also i'm
going to define y which is the same
thing but for the 2020 pie chart now
let's look at the chart we will want to
know how many degrees are in this
section k
at first glance it might look like it's
a third 120 like this one down here but
actually it's not if this one here l is
90 degrees
m is 120 and in total this has to add to
360 then k will actually be
150 degrees over here it's a bit more
simple we've got 90 90 and so this one
would have to be 180. if we can find x
then the problem will be solved by
finding 150 times x that will be how
many tvs this chunk represents if that's
150x then this one here is 90x 120x
since the number of m brand televisions
increases in number by 40
then this section here will be
120x
plus 40. and since l decreases in number
by 25 this one here will be
90x minus 25. but these segments can
also be represented using y
this one is also
90 degrees times y and this one down
here is 180y
and since these represent the same
number of tvs in this chunk we can write
90x minus 25 is equal to 90y
and for this one 120x
plus 40
is equal to 180y this is our key to
solving the problem we've got two
unknowns but also two equations so we
can solve this for both x and y
rearranging the top one for y and
subbing that into the second one i get x
to be three over two remember what we
wanted to solve the problem was 150x so
150
times 3 over 2 well that is 450 over 2
which is equal to 225
meaning that c is the correct answer now
it took me a few goes to get there but
if you found this easily then
congratulations you're as smart as a
turkish 13 year old i can't help but
think that if you already are studying
so hard for exams this early that by the
time you get to those tougher university
entrance exams you may have already
burnt out but it seems like even getting
into some of the best high schools is a
competitive process this is a question
from that notorious university entrance
exam this is from the 2021 ayt
mathematics paper
translated it says that p of x is a
fourth degree polynomial with real
coefficients and it gives the inequality
that p of x is bigger than or equal to x
it gives us three values of p of x at x
is one two and three and it asks us to
find the value of p of x at x is equal
to 4. now on an axis of x and p of x
this line here represents where p of x
is equal to x a function is called p of
x but it could just as easily have been
called y and you may recognize this as
more commonly called the line y equals x
this inequality tells us that the value
of our function will always exist above
or at this line so in this region here
in fact we can plot some of the points
at x is equal to one p of x is also
equal to one so that point is on the
line the same thing happens at x is
equal to three in between at x is equal
to two the value of p of x is 4 so it
will be somewhere up here and since we
know it's a 4th degree polynomial or a
quartic we know it'll be a wibbly-wobbly
shape but because it can't pass down
into this region down here it must look
something like this
and our question wants us to find the
value when x is equal to 4 so when it's
somewhere up here finding the value of
this polynomial at any x value would be
easy if only we had the equation of this
line but the equation of this line is
slightly hard to find when we look at it
from this perspective instead let's take
a look at our inequality if we subtract
x from both sides we have that p of x
minus x is bigger than or equal to zero
subtracting x off this function makes it
something that's easier to find an
equation for because it will intersect
the x-axis plotting p of x minus x we
get something that looks more like this
and you can see where i've got these
points from i just subtracted x from
these values here 1 minus 1 would give
us a value of 0 there 4 minus 2 gives
the coordinate 2 2
and 3 minus 3 gives the coordinate 3 0
i know the x intercepts of this quartic
so i can actually write its equation
i'd get k which is some scale factor
that we're yet to find
x minus 1 squared times x minus 3
squared if you're slightly unfamiliar
with cortex you may wonder how i know
that these are both squared well i can
tell what they call the multiplicity of
these zeros by actually looking at the
graph
also called the order the multiplicity
is how many zeros are at the x-intercept
for example if the multiplicity was 1
that would be if this bracket wasn't
squared it was just a single value of x
in that case the x-intercept would be
cut in a linear fashion the intercept
would look something like this or like
this
with a multiplicity of 2 that's when we
would see an x squared and the intercept
would look like a quadratic something
like this or this this is for a
multiplicity of 2 but also 4
6 8 and in fact any even number and a
multiplicity of 3
or of 5
7 9 and any other odd number we would
see something that looks like this where
the intercept is in there fun fact is
the higher this number of multiplicity
the flatter the section will look our
x-intercepts come down and turn around
and that sort of quadratic function so
that's why we can say that that would be
squared if we're dealing with a cortex
that is a power of x to the 4 then the
total multiplicities added together will
equal 4. we do still want to find the
value of k and we can do that using
these points here if we used x equals 1
we'd end up with 1 minus 1 is 0 that
would all be 0 and it wouldn't be useful
for finding k same thing would happen if
we used 3 that's probably why they've
given us this one in between if p of two
minus two is equal to two
we'd have k
two minus one is one squared
two minus 3
is minus 1 squared that would all be 1
and k would just be equal to 2. so this
would be our final equation for p of x
minus x
and that's all we need to be able to
find p of 4. plugging in x is equal to 4
it works out to give us the answer of
22. luckily that's one of our options
and so we can say that b is the right
answer i know that in the real exam you
get a lot less time than i've taken here
but i'm trying to explain things as i go
especially if this problem is an
unfamiliar type for you what makes the
exam even harder is that this might be
an unfamiliar question to almost
everyone it doesn't look like it appears
in last year's exam and so there's not
really any warning to prepare for
something like this
interestingly this exam made the news in
turkey this week after a decision from
the council of higher education to
change the minimum passing score
whilst entry to the top universities
will remain very competitive students
could still be placed in a less
competitive program after getting as
little as one question correct
in turkey there are many higher
education institutes but they're not all
of the same quality
perhaps this decision could lead to more
low quality institutes offering degrees
that don't help to reduce the country's
unemployment
or we'll see private universities now
accepting anyone who's willing to pay
the tuition fee
thanks for watching this video and again
let me know your thoughts down in the
comments this video is in honor of
today's patreon cat of the day latte
sent in by connor
[Music]
you